i really wanted to wear this dress like
i it was really important to me and
you know it actually taught me a lot
about my lifestyle and my health kim
kardashian says she did a complete 180
with her health after wearing the iconic
marilyn monroe gown to the med gala
revealing on the today show she's
dropped even more weight since then
afterwards i continued to eat really
healthy i mean i'm down 21 pounds now
i'm not trying to lose any more weight
but i have more energy than ever i cut
out so much sugar a lot of junk food i
was eating i didn't even realize that a
lot of fried foods
and i just completely changed my
lifestyle yeah when kim puts her mind to
something she's fiercely dedicated
something we learned when kim first
stepped out in the show-stopping look i
tried it on it didn't fit me and so i
looked at them and i said give me like
three weeks and i i had to lose 16
pounds
down today to be able to fit this but i
it was such a challenge it was like a
role right i was determined
but kim's drastic method to fitting into
maryland's gown drew criticism some
saying the reality star went too far you
just gotta roll with it at the time kim
defended her decision telling the new
york times she saw it like she was
prepping for a part in the film
comparing herself to actors like renee
zellweger and christian bale who've gone
through major on-screen transformations
it was a challenge to myself i don't
think it was something that i would wish
to do again it ain't great for your
health we think kim would agree she
doubled down reiterating that this was a
personal choice not something she
recommends for others quote i wasn't
saying hey everyone why don't you go
lose this weight in a short period of
time
as for what kim is focused on these days
she's still all about having glam
moments but it starts with her skin the
41 year old just dropped her new
skincare line and it says it's given her
a new perspective on aging at my age
there is a lot that goes into making
sure that my skin is well taken care of
and i wanted to share exactly what i use
i think you get to a place where you're
at peace with aging and i'm totally
there but i will do everything i can to
make sure that it is
i look and feel my best if you ask me it
seems like love has kim glowing these
days she's been dating funny man pete
davidson since october and says he's
actually the one who keeps her on her
skin a game i've learned so much about
skin care actually from him he's really
into skin care really yes
yes he is um that's like our thing we we
go to dermatologists and facials and we
yeah yeah you know what they say a
couple that does face scrubs together
stays together yes
[Music]
you